That's the only way for justice to be served and non binary.
Yes,
but what does that mean?
She's in her gender can switch throughout the film depending on where she is on
binary gender flux,
gender fluid,
gender fluid.
Sorry,
what's your Pronoun Today?
A czar.
I'm always wanting to have a z in there.
These are cool.
Yeah.
Zoro Zara.
I feel like your highness.
Oh,
that's good.
That's a good,
yeah,
that's good.
Yeah.
Your Highness can be a guy or a girl.
Whoa,
whoa.
It's gender neutral.
Your Highness.
Now if you said I'm a princess,
I would go,
okay,
well you're gendering yourself.
That's true.
Yeah,
that's true.
And I refuse to do that.
I have two little boys and you know we forced them to be gender neutral.
They don't,
I was watching a show,
not a legit show on that from Cambridge.
This couple was raising their kid gender neutral.
They look,
they have two kids and they're both like wearing like whatever they're wearing
like weird clothes.
I like.
It didn't necessarily,
literally they were wearing boys clothes,
a girl's clothes and they didn't call them girls or boys and let them play with
anything they wanted and they didn't call them boys.
What did they say?
It was fucking weird.
It was just some poor guy who stuck with some crazy bitch and she's,
you know,
and he was probably trying really hard to be like progressive and like figure
out a what,
you know,
how do we not gender our children and yeah and it's interesting you do that
voice cause they all do up speak.
They do most the only way to show your progressive because if you didn't notice
conservative people just don't talk like that.
Need to stop the caravan before it gets to the wall.
Donald Trump is our savior cause he's like the one who really appreciates like
American values and never hear that it's,
it's only,
it's a super liberal calling.
It is.
Back to this non binary,
uh,
we,
we did a clip on your mom's house.
There is a couple somewhere in the Netherlands and they had a three year old Zim
or child and another dessert
and every day they would ask the three year old,
what gender do you feel like today?
And I'm like,
boy.
I have a almost three year old.
I'm pretty sure he doesn't know.
He doesn't think in terms of,
yeah,
he's like,
I don't know,
I'm whatever.
But to put the pressure like what are you today?
What are you feeling?
My eight year old loves to play with things like race cars and she used to love
to play with trucks and she used to love she's,
yeah,
she,
she loves to play with superheroes and things like that.
Like some of them are like very boy,
but again,
she loves pink and she likes getting her nails done and she likes looking pretty
and she's,
there's some cool shit that boys like that girls like to like,
she's pretty aggressive,
which she takes me to my main classes and she throws boys around.
She gets like super hyped up when she has to wrestle with boys.
She really,
she has,
it's crazy to watch like a little psycho aggressive eight year old,
but she's also like really sweet,
like the sweetest kid.
Everybody just gets like real competitive with that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
They say that that's the magic age eight,
nine in girls and then,
uh,
where they're very confident.
It's like the end of the confidence era and then puberty strikes and the
hormones take over and the pressure.
Yeah.
To be sexy.
So PIPPI Longstocking that cool.
Last character who was doing that shit?
Remember?
PIPPI Longstocking beating up cops.
She said she had like a treasure trove,
so she was,
uh,
she was a millionaire on her own.
Her Dad was a pirate.
Really?
Hell yeah,
I do watch those on Pippi Longstocking thanks very much.
And remember the name.
I don't remember the narrative.
Oh,
she was great.
And it was subtitled poorly.
And her lips,
you know,
didn't match up with what she was saying.
It was on channel five and la every Sunday afternoon.
Where's it from originally?
Uh,
Sweden,
I believe Astrid Lindgren wrote these books about her daughter who was that age,
eight,
eight years old is a magic age.
There she is the original one.
It'd be long stockings.
And she said,
girls are kind of smelly,
kind of awkward.
And that's before puberty robs you of your,
uh,
you know,
why not fuck this new school?
I'm talking about,
oh,
seven days,
bitch.
Oh,
there she goes.
She's got a monkey.
Hey,
had a monkey.
I know you love monkeys.
Monkeys.
Is that a monkey?
A scarf?
Yeah.
I didn't choose bag.
She beat the shit out of people.
Wow.
Uh,
but yeah,
I think I play with the boy stuff too,
because my dad,
I was raised by a single dad somewhat,
so he gave me like a BMX dirt bike and I would write it in the La River,
you know?
And then I liked dolls too.
And that's what makes a female comics.
So you might.